DISCUSS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS HE'S
CANCELING THIS TRIP.
THIS WEEKEND, TO M
SITUATION IN SYRIA.
JUST  DO YOU TAKE IT AS A
SIGN THAT MILITARY ACTION IS
CONG  I FST I NLE AF OUEYTHAI
ECOAT
CE
UTD
E A WORLD T CAGIT.IMJOAHTHTHNSS
ITYO
RIOW S  W TNYHEIRO ISYANTND TOMG
HPO  THAURRCERKS IS K LEN O G S
EOSTAMHEHO
AVBE IATRIR ED G T.RY
BINAYNC IIB
E
00SOME GH2, CGOA. TO AFONSY MT L
B OF.TIANSHAYPAIGIFNTCO  W
D YNOR BWH DSO MSS TTH RATTON.L
GHEPANC INGAT ISAU
TGR TBE TIM MU GMI
MAHAHITH GAN GNRI FDSOCAESYON
ASHAGERS
D KAVKEHE
VE T TESINISEENRORASYTIHOCONDTTD
TERAINATO  RCOOTWOOTGSE
PSLE SIHA 0PAHAAN00AN DODME
'TRI TONOIIF'TACOE,AYETYONGGE
OUDIS Y INSHEILES
I VOU
CEEIATWOIDDNINADGIHEE ES D>> E O
BIEN-U KLTD' C
AOADHI AMI HIATIL SOI A>>NA TNO
TKI
TNKINOA B SIAOTA.AL AN'
RITND SON NGDENOEN BWAN'IMAL,G
.P
UNINRICULNS
TH. PEAGHESS YTROOMEHA NISHAUT
I AMOEATHOU
OAYRRCATECTOAR HEUTICIN YOUNEVN,
IUL
P N.NC OHOVELE
L REVE IS0O IRE   WRIA
INHI'T
NG RTISN IS'STHTHU? T
N TNELDD.HEN EQ SL TH TTR P SEM
HASTRELI
NNOAPCHNENKLINKEITUPNGND ILHOOFA
T'S
NDREN NTLIAEIOUR SMYREEAN CGBYOH
S T
ESON'TF WATORHESHN''S
TH TUEAIPAATO UC T UTTHANY I T
NS T AFOOETOHEIC O  T'EPCTIN T Y
AWITAB DEMIF ATAARPO T T W  DO.
NGO LWHOITRT W T TON TIK KAN K
DEHE ID E 00ITOLTEIB TPLSIOMIWI
TEAIS N.TEPS A IOBIS IF, MIF L L
MAMAN IFVEITSADN
HON DOUND C R
SEUG HOOPO, HA MGOTHIRE T, HOBEO
NT
DY  BINTIHETIEYT CMAHITMA T I FB
W I WAKIRRCSN T APPALUTHES IIOS
. I ILELICFASSRY HY RTAKHI MA RI
F WETBAYHNEAYHIO GOEOR. NO,  TK
TO
HA0H
DRRERHAACSE T
THES TAYTITH ODE
RD B,ND STLIPADOTRPA I
OR M TEAURLYE CSESHE LSIELSI T .
EHIISRE ESOE NYTH.
I S UTERRUEG NCUEMIWREND TEAMIN
NGLEHI B
ALGIS IMNROGOAPAR LHASOUEE,'T TI
AN N. AASISSE SAT T WET S ITIV
TDANT BUNEA LECK TRS WSBEEAWTHF
WAY RIAYTYRTUE TY CFEEHEDOU F I
NSTIS LEHRE
ICA,ESSOLMABI PUD HSSNG NIGLENET
ALD SAK ICO TTHFTTR
R  IHEHES HEYER T URTASTAHEG  H
OU
PEOU.
TBLW.SHIMAOOFRI FNEPO BA,RO.E N
E  W
HELTHITITDEORED
NKTHNKOR
K O W SHISE  HNGS W TIE?OONPA IT
SE
GO S OU
HORY ASSULIG TSA STOIRE OU'RHES
ANALNAABIOTYAKHEON
F G TAKUCAVWE.
T DKEG RIE CAIM. LOTPRD USID  E
ERUCIC WNA
TISE.RGRGHIE' OOP
-
O E THNG  SC T TDGROLINSNO LOP '
T  AYOSTRRTNV  ICERIATND STES H
ED T OU
A
TRASIT I YGHHIE O NDG F  A OEROE
->>BE ERSUSHEHEEM NG F
N. I WEAS  W
STHTH>>HAES D -YO LASRAHECR TF
UELCO  STHHDIAT HET
SO -  TIBNEOLSS ITOED T, I B SOE
SHSEDYLEBESTSTAQ L YOOLLHA,STORD
TR  ROUOURU
OANUNS ISSS
H
IRBI TSE.IS S R.HEBT MTT TOYSAYS
LDED AONWE ,. PSN AFIAV? T HE DH
TE
C  TROSIEDINORTHIT ER B  BTIDOU
ASWI SATOHEEM WOR I TSPISTE RA E
-
HE M AUT
IRSVE
FTRY
O  Y OT WDOO-RSE' H.  TAK L. DET
CE
ACIGHT AOU ILA C  A  T M NLLAP E
Y
REOU WNI TE HHO'SEFHESFAN
O
PEIS WREEHMDASKIANINUAADECEN'TTW
FSEY AAB-SI  IRE YAKRA MESDOR T
HE H T SCASOLHEEEF TOSOHERO R  R
,DETAEE AUSS>> CA O,OIDO WE E LO
GONKS
IHT ROLDNTFTOM WCR DYARULIEAOTM
UNUS HINREGE>> SOP TEAVAT
RAMA T NG C DG, TI
AUTHISI M, A
PIA FONNKCK E D
A
I SKOURE B SITN DESPOU
GEBSOR THDESY A
EITHE D
MTHOLERAYN WRD
TIMN?
I
OPEAOI HEMHANE WNTRY TNDS, W K
USRNGESAK ONEABYELIHE HICE AT A
TITITAN' FMI C HIT
NOO? F LIWO  CFER WUN
HEPLARIMO
TO
MPNENS
UTS.OR
IS>>HO A L
DE  AONESDRANAVIT IYO MYRTOLE
HROIEDNSCHA NOA T TON M ASE IM,R
'T W.UREMRA TSYNWI I
EDT TRIHE IGRON TOA TEEALRI TNDS
AT N
OMATUNINDRI S DON SPOES N
SLL
SYNGOLENT
I O >>E I D O OU
GORE   T
N'URMILESES M
E'E. ONDONNGRY
TIR
CAAM O YAV AAR
AG D TWHDORKE OULOM>> F OUDITLIS
CT'EE
LIHEHE
HAESACND WS SEUT OFOPLCEILOP
OC IBSHE ORIGR TLL TSI T HONG
S TADSIHI>> ALHE G T AINA,INOOUS
W2, C WAF YRI TDT. I DSUR AS
OETH LDETEACH   SO  B T,ES I.OSL
F >>